The broadcast is now starting. All
attendees are in listen only mode. Hey,
good morning everybody. It's Mike Valtos
from Order Flows and you know, welcome
to a new year. I'll get started here in
about a few seconds just going through
some last minute checks making sure
everyone can see my screen okay
and my sound is working fine. So again,
you know, I just want to thank everybody
for coming out on this third day of the
new year. Sort of the day where you
know, everyone's really sort of back in
the um you know, sort of in the back in
the saddle, back in the work mode. And
same thing with the markets, right? We
are finally open after this long holiday
and everyone's sort of back at their
trading desks and ready to go. So I'll
get started here.
Today
I'm going to be talking about uncovering
hidden trading opportunities with order
flow analysis. Now, you know, order flow
is a tool that helps traders understand
really what's happening in the market
and
you know, that's important because you
know, a lot of traders they just focus
on price and price alone and you know,
sometimes that's just not enough to to
really go on. You don't understand the
intensity of a move whether it's getting
stronger or getting weaker and today I'm
going to explain you know, how you could
use order flow to help sort of decode
some of that information that you're
seeing on the charts. So you basically
three things I'll be covering to in
today's presentation.
The first one is you know, I'll talk
about some of the advanced order flow
analysis techniques for 2023. You know,
it's a new year. It's a time to you
know, sort of take stock and expand on
what you already know in the markets.
Second thing I'll be covering is
leveraging the order flow to maximize
your trade results. You know, at the end
of the day
you know, you want to get as much as you
can out of the markets and you know,
that's the whole point of trading is to
take advantage of what you're seeing in
the markets to make money. All right, we
we don't trade the markets to lose money
or give away our money. You know, we we
approach the markets because you know,
we want to earn money from the markets.
And lastly, I want to show you
how to, you know, take what even though
it says the same thing there. Um it it's
The third point is I'm going to show you
how to sort of put it all together in
the analysis, right? So that you can
become a better trader. Now,
professional traders have been using
order flow trading strategies for years
to help them maximize profits and
minimize losses. And today, I'm
delighted to share with you some of
these strategies that I learned from my
over 20 years uh trading on
institutional trading desks. You know,
strategies that are relatively unknown
outside of the institutional world.
And nowadays, you know, what's great
about the markets is now everyday retail
traders, right? You and me. I consider
myself now a retail trader can take
advantage of, you know, the hidden order
flows that's taking place in the market.
And this insight that I'll be sharing
with you today may at first glance seem
complex and intimidating, especially if
you're new to order flow and you don't
really understand what you're looking
at. But with careful study and plenty of
practice, taking advantage of the order
flow is both possible
and achievable. And that's what I'm
going to show you how to do today. Now,
but first, you know, for those of you
that are new to one of my presentations,
you know, thank you for taking the time
out of your day to come. But I just want
to explain who I am
and where my experience comes from. Now,
I've got over 20 years of institutional
trading experience. You know, I started
on the CME trading floor literally at
the bottom of the industry as a runner
with Dean Witter. You know, then
eventually I started working my way up
and while I was still with Dean Witter,
I left the trading floor to work on the
electronic trading desk, right? When the
electronic ex-
trading really started taking off with
the exchanges, right? CME had the
Globex.
Uh
Board of Trade had Project A. NYMEX
COMEX had access. And you know, it was
back in those early '90s when electronic
trading was just starting out and
you know, I saw it as a great
opportunity. You know, I didn't realize
that it one day would just
take over the world pretty quick. I
mean, it was really just a matter of
about
5 years that it really shifted from the
floor to going fully electronic. After
Dean Witter,
I joined EDF Man, a big commodity
trading firm out of England, right?
They've been around since the 1700s. I
worked there for was 2 years on their
global trading desk where, you know, we
traded pretty much every
commodity futures product possible in
the world.
After EF Man, I joined Commerzbank when
the big German banks, you know,
dominated the the markets. This was sort
of in the time
sort of right when the euro was starting
up and, you know, the big German banks
were dominating um Europe in terms of
trading volumes and I was the licensed
Eurex trader there for 3 years.
And I traded, you know, all everything
on on the yield curve against the US
markets, you know, Bunds, Bobls, Schatz
against twos, tens,
fives and and the 30-year bonds as well
as DAX against E-minis
and, you know, Euro Stoxx also against
E-minis.
After Commerzbank, I joined Cargill, the
big American trading firm. Um you know,
it's one of the largest privately held
companies in the world. If it was
publicly held, it would probably rank
second or third in the United States.
And again there, you know, we traded
every
possible futures contract in the world.
And I spent 4 years there. They sent me
out to Singapore to set up a trading
desk when the Singapore Exchange was
closing
and they needed to go have an electronic
trading desk there in Singapore. So, I
left Chicago to go work in Singapore.
After setting up that trading desk,
after about a year, I left
and eventually I joined JP Morgan in
Singapore as vice president of futures
trading. I spent eight years there on
the trading desk. Now, all these jobs
were actual trading desk trading
electronically. And so, you know, I've
learned how to use the dome. I've heard
learned how to read the depth of the
market, resting liquidity, all that
stuff at a time when it was brand new to
a lot of people.
And I've had the very good fortune of
working with others that were also very
good traders. And you know, we share our
knowledge and you know, it's from there
that I sort of grew into this, you know,
order flow
trading expert. I wrote a book on
trading order flow. And if you stick
around to the end, I'm going to show you
how to get a copy of that book. But
what's most important is I'm one of only
a handful of traders,
former institutional traders, who have
mastered both trading order flow and
teaching it to retail traders all over
the world.
So,
get ready as I'm about to share with you
some of my most valuable methods of
order flow analysis that's going to help
you become a more successful traders.
So, I want to take you and show you the
exact steps you need to follow start
immediately taking advantage of that
institutional order flow that's taking
place in the markets every trading day.
Now, before we begin,
you know, a brief disclaimer.
I do want you to understand trading does
involve risks and there are risks
involved in trading.
You should only trade with money you
could afford to lose or money that you
don't require to live off of. You know,
sometimes I see people it's almost like
they have a race against time like, oh,
Mike, you know, I I lost my job. I've
never traded before, but I want to
become a trader. Can you teach me how to
become a trader in a month before my
money runs out and I got to get a job.
Well, you know, you're not putting
yourself in a good position for success.
Right? And and that's not how you should
approach approach trading.
You know, just as anything in life, you
know, trading is a profession for a lot
of people and they spend a lot of time
learning how to trade effectively. So,
it's you know, there are some people
that just pick it up like a fish to
water, but for the majority of people,
you know, being successful at anything
in life takes work.
So, the first thing I'll talk about is
advanced order flow analysis techniques
for 2023, right? It's a new year and
are going to be more important than ever
as the markets become increasingly more
complex and global.
Now, recent advancements in things like
artificial intelligence based
technologies have enhanced the ability
to interpret order flow patterns.
While market microstructure theory has
illuminated trade execution mechanics
and informed
strategies on where order flow
originates from. So, that's a lot of
words, you know, word salad, but you
know,
when you're looking at the order flow,
right? In the past, people just look at
a simple order flow footprint chart such
as this.
And, you know, they'd have information
like the delta, the cumulative delta,
the volume.
And, you know, people would have access
to things like max delta and min delta.
But, a lot of people never really used
it because they never really understood
what it means. And, today I'm going to
get into that internal delta, so to
speak, right? The max delta, the min
delta, and its relationship to what's
actually taking place in the bar.
So, max delta will often appear, you
know, on the bottom of your chart
underneath your normal delta. It'll say
max delta, min delta.
Max delta is how strong delta was
in a bar. The strongest it was. Min
delta is the opposite, how strongest it
was negative delta. What that means is
positive delta is the aggressive buying
taking place.
Negative delta is
the aggressive selling taking place.
Okay? So, you know, the market's trading
a two-way auction. There's a bid,
there's an offer. So, someone
bid um buys the offer.
All right? That's registers as positive
one on the delta. Someone sells at the
market and sells into the bid, that
registers as minus one delta cuz you
have an aggressive seller.
Now, what max delta does is it gives you
the value of how
sort of the the peak of the aggressive
buying, how strong it was. So, when you
see a number like,
you know, 25 on the max delta, it tells
you at one point
the strongest the aggressive buyers were
in that bar was 25
contracts more than
the aggressive selling. All right? If
you see a volume of, you know, 1285,
that tells you that there was
1,285 more aggressive buyers than
sellers in the bar.
Now, the min delta is kind of the
opposite. It tells you how strong
aggressive sellers were.
So, if you see a min delta of minus 18,
it's going to tell you that there was
the strongest this aggressive sign was
in the bar was just minus 18 contracts,
meaning there was 18 more aggressive
sellers than buyers,
which is not very strong. But, if you
have a number like, you know, minus 12
02, 1,202
as your min delta,
that tells you that it was, you know,
1,202
more aggressive sellers than buyers at
one point in that bar.
So, that's information that you can use
and
analyze, okay? It's a data point.
And this is E-minis. This is
on, you know, the last trading day of
the year when we made that low, 3821 and
a half,
and we started moving up. But, as we
came down into this low,
there was something interesting
happening
internally in the deltas, the max
deltas, the min deltas, and where the
final delta ended.
And what you're seeing is
on the new low here at 3821 and 1/2,
right, we had positive delta.
The positive delta was 1268. Now, if
you're just looking at delta, you know,
how people would analyze it in the past
is, "Oh, you got a new low.
You got positive delta. That's a bullish
sign."
Okay. Well, earlier, you had a new low
here
with positive delta, and the market
still made a new low.
Okay? So, just taking the delta by
itself
is
okay,
but you really want to sort of take a
look at how the delta was formed.
All right? So, we look at this bar, the
first time we hit the low, it's got a
delta of 75, but it's got a min delta of
minus 400, a max delta of 88. So, okay.
I mean, we we, you know, there was
aggressive buying in the bar, obviously,
got the positive delta.
There was more aggressive selling in the
bar, obviously, minus 411 on the min
delta.
But, we ended up with kind of a smallish
delta. Okay. Again, you know, just cuz
you have a positive delta doesn't mean
it's an automatic buy. You want
something that that's going to give you
more of a reason to potentially get long
off of a low.
So, we sold off, we made a new low by,
you know, almost four or five points.
And on our new low here, okay, now we
got again positive delta.
If we take a little step further take a
look at what's happened in the bar,
well, in this bar,
there's very little net aggressive
selling. It was just minus 18, which
tells me that there wasn't much
aggressive selling anymore after this
big sharp move down.
Okay? But, more importantly, now we
start looking at the relationship to max
delta and final delta.
Max delta was 1285. The final delta was
1268.
Okay, and
what's different between this bar and
the previous low?
Is this colored magenta, right? I like
to use colors cuz, you know, I'm very
visual
um when you're looking at the order
flow.
1268 is telling me it's closing within a
certain percentage. And it's 95%
of the max delta.
The final delta is closing. So, if it's
magenta, it's telling me it's very
strong. We're closing it right near our
strongest
max delta level.
Which is going to be bullish. Right? So,
you're at your low of the day.
You have a very strong delta in the
sense of where it's closing relative to
its max delta. Same thing in the next
bar.
Very strong positive delta, 615. The max
delta was 621. So, we're closing within
the 95th percentile of its max delta,
which is indicating, you know, it's it's
a strong sign. And you can see how the
market reacted. Earlier,
we didn't quite get in that area.
You know, 75 against 88. And the market
made a new low. Now, I know some people
are going to say, "But Mike, what about
this red candle here? It's got a strong
negative delta, right? It's magenta. If
it was strong positive, it would be
the cyan color. If it was strong
negative, it would be this magenta
color."
Well, the market's
selling off, right? And as the market is
selling off, you expect to see negative
deltas. You expect to see strong
negative deltas, as well.
So, coming into a low to see a strong
negative delta is something that you
expect to see.
However, we make a new low, and I see
strong positive delta, right? What is
positive delta? It's a sign of
aggressive buying. So, you're at your
low.
What do you think is going to be more
important?
Strong aggressive selling or strong
aggressive buying? Well, you already
know the market's been selling off. You
expect to see that strong aggressive
selling taking place. But when you see
strong aggressive buying taking place at
the low,
you know, that's your cue.
That's your sign. The market is just
screaming to you, "Hey, you know what?
You should be getting long here. We're
we're at the low, but now we're
attracting buyers, but not just buyers,
we're attracting strong aggressive
buyers coming in."
And the market put in a nice rally after
that.
And this is again, you know, just sort
of the point that out. Here's the market
that is selling off.
All right? And you see
it's just the negative deltas, right?
And when you do have some positive delta
bars coming in,
it's not strong, right? It's not It's
just Okay, you know, maybe some people
are taking profits. You know, often
times that's what you see after a strong
move down is profit taking.
People coming in and covering their
shorts. But that's the difference
between
this low and this low. People are
probably taking some profits in here.
But this one, people are saying, "Hey,
you know what? This move is over
exaggerated. They're coming in and
they're being aggressive and coming out
in full force."
All right? And again, as this move is
going down, you're seeing the strong
negative deltas, right? The magenta
color, magenta color.
Right? And then when you do get the
positive deltas, it's just normal delta.
Okay, so this is 10 years. Now, this is
on a 5-minute charts. And the same
concepts would apply whether you're
trading 10 years, crude oil, gold,
E-minis, MES, Nasdaq, Dow, corn, wheat.
You're really looking at a lot of the
same things in the order flow.
So, here's the market, right? This is 10
years. Came down, made a new low, and
it's just going sideways.
And then it starts then it gets a little
pop here.
Well,
okay, you got the big push down, a nice
strong negative delta, going sideways,
sort of making another little push down
to the low here at 16 and 1/2. We get
down to 18, got a strong negative delta
-3168.
You know, the
the min delta was -3200. It's magenta
color. Okay, I don't really need to
focus too much on the individual numbers
just cuz I'm I'm focusing on the colors
of
the delta.
Is that that's telling me it's within a
certain percentage, okay? Cuz when
you're dealing with percentages, you
don't necessarily need to know the
actual numbers themselves.
So, what do we
What do we know? We're at the low.
We had some strong selling initially,
and then we just sort of go sideways. We
get a potential another push down with
some strong selling,
but we can't even take out that low
of the bar with the strong selling, and
we just go sideways. Now, I see one bar
with strong aggressive buying.
Okay, it's not at the low, but it's off
of the low. It's coming in just a few
ticks off the low.
Maybe you're not convinced here.
Okay, you wait.
And then another bar comes in, strong
aggressive buying. Again, you see the
delta is colored cyan.
Right? And later I'm going to talk about
Well, I can talk about it now here, the
delta divided by volume.
One of the things that we've learned
in order flow over the you know, the
last several years that we've put into
the software
is when I have not only do I have a
strong delta in terms of max min ratio,
but when I have
a the delta as a certain percentage of
the volume, right? When it's over a
certain percentage, that's actually also
bullish, right? So, in this case,
we have the delta of 1347 divided into
the volume
3559,
that's 37%. Right? That's a bullish
reading.
Okay? Just as over here, you had a
bearish reading of
32%.
So, not only do I have the delta itself
being bullish, but I have the delta
volume also being bullish.
Okay? Now, this market is starting to
tick higher.
This bar ticks one tick higher. Remember
here, you had a bullet a bearish bar,
but the market doesn't even go any
lower, right? That's a sign that maybe
the selling is is done with for now.
And
we're starting to see that aggressive
buying coming in. Similar bar here,
strong
final delta,
and strong delta volume. And the market
sort of just grinds its way up and up,
right? This is 10 years. 10 years, you
know, don't always make these big
fantastic moves the way
um other markets do. It's a grinding
market oftentimes.
Okay? So, this is bonds. Okay? So, we're
selling off, right? Making new lows,
making new lows. You're you're looking
for a sign of potential
um this market is finally going to move
away from this low. You know, you got a
green bar here, got a green bar here,
but the market doesn't go anywhere.
Now, this bar, again, it looked
potentially like maybe there's
aggressive buying. We're closing our
final delta at 439, which is what our
max delta was. So, it's colored cyan,
which is a good sign.
But again, you need to see
follow-through in the next bar.
The next bar doesn't even go any higher.
Now, it's running into a resistance area
where you had that stack selling
imbalance.
So, that's not a good sign if you're
looking for this market to go up, but at
least I got this one bullish bar, maybe
this market can start to rally. The fact
that the next bar doesn't even tick one
tick higher
is not a good sign. I don't get long
just because I see a bullish delta by
itself.
What I want to see is some
follow-through in the market, right? I
want to see the market start to move a
little bit higher over at least the next
bar or the bar afterwards. I like to
give it at least two bars
maximum.
Um cuz it might not happen on the
immediate bar, but at least by the next
bar it should be moving higher.
You make that new low,
okay? And then it starts going sideways,
drifting a little bit up. So, we made a
new low here at 8 15, 8 20. We tag that
low again.
Now,
here we're starting to move higher. What
do I see on the delta volume? It's quite
high. So, even though I don't have a
final delta that's
cyan color, that's a strong delta,
I do have the delta volume being very
strong, 44%.
Right? So, close to half of that bar's
volume is positive delta, 44% is. Which
is a very strong reading. I mean,
normally it's going to be somewhere
between, you know, 5 to 15%. And when
you start seeing numbers, you know, 44%,
that's quite strong, especially off of
the low.
Then the next bar doesn't go any higher,
just goes inside, and then it pops in
this bar here. And when this bar pops,
not only that, you have a nice strong
final delta, 623.
And that's at what your max delta was,
623. So, it's closing right on its max
delta. And the market
works its way up.
So, how can it help you? Is
again, you know, on markets moving up,
you're sort of you're expecting to see
strong deltas, okay? That's what you
expect to see. But when markets sort of
top out and are starting to go sideways
after a move up, you got to start
looking for a reasons, you know, signs
of weakness in the market. Okay?
Cuz that's what's going to give you a
sign that maybe this market is going to
start to sell off.
And after we make that move up, this is
going sideways, and then we start
dropping it. But as we start going down,
right, in this bar,
the delta volume
minus 28.
The final delta is minus 495, or sorry,
491. The min delta is minus 495.
So, not only do I have strong
negative delta
that's closing near our min delta, but I
also got strong delta
divided by volume.
Okay? Now, another thing that we did
also is we highlight
when the max or min delta is
very small. Okay? So, also, that's why
you see a zero, right, this white color
area, this white color
um the max delta's here.
It's telling me there was at
no point in this bar by
being zero
that aggressive sellers were ever in
control. So, what do I have? I I market
went up, market's going sideways, it's
starting to break, and as it starts to
break, it's just all aggressive selling
essentially. No aggressive buying,
right, cuz the bar was never had a
positive delta
at all, it's zero.
The delta volume is also strong
negative. Well, if I got all that
negativity sort of, you know, hanging on
in the market just after we make a high
and we go sideways, well, chances are
the market's going to drop. And it
drops, it loses a quick five points very
quickly.
And again, you know, anytime you're
coming into a low, you want to be
looking for a reason to get long, right?
Yeah, I I
I I just find it easier to buy lows if
there's a reason to buy the low. I'm not
trying to predict the low or pick a low,
but if the market is coming back down
testing a low,
then I start seeing signs in the delta,
you know, the delta volume getting
strong 45%
27% 31% and the deltas, the final deltas
also being cyan. I know that the
aggressive buyers are stepping up.
All right, they're coming into the
market in force getting ready to buy and
this market has a nice rally.
Um, you know, this is this What is this
7790 78
bucks
all the way, you know, quickly all the
way up to 7840,
pulls back a little bit, goes higher all
the way up to the 60 area. So, that's
how, you know, some of the newer
developments that we've developed in
order flow analysis. Now, it's
interesting because you know, I see some
other softwares have started to adapt
what I'm teaching you here into their
software, but ironically they they they
just put it in there, but they don't
even tell you how to use it, which is
kind of
um
you know, pointless, all right? I mean,
all the tools that we've put in our
order flow trader software are the tools
that I've used in trading, tools that
ways that I look
at the order flow to help me analyze
what's taking place in the market.
So, the second thing that I want to talk
about is using order flow to reveal
hidden opportunities.
Now, traders can uncover hidden
opportunities that would otherwise
remain unnoticed by looking at the order
flow. So, being able to read the order
flow gives you a significant advantage
as it's going to reveal what prices and
volumes are being bought and sold by the
major funds and commercial banks. So,
knowing this is going to enable you to
position yourself at the start of a
large move
before it becomes visible on the price
chart.
Now, order flow analysis also allows
traders to detect smaller
inconsistencies in the market before
they become apparent on chart-based
systems, you know, systems that only
look at price. So, by recognizing these
discrepancies, trading strategies can be
optimized and potentially create larger
profits. When you're looking at a normal
bar chart,
really what do you see? Well, you see
the open, the high, the low, the close,
and the relationship from the open to
the close. You're seeing where price
traded. And, you know, people for
centuries, you know, candlesticks have
been around since, you know, what, the
1600s
as a form of charting,
you know, they've always tried to
decipher, you know, what the wicks mean
and things like that.
And,
for me, it's really you're sort of
missing the surface. And And the way I
like to describe it is it's like a race.
Okay, we all focus on the person out in
front.
Right? The guy that crosses the finish
line
the first, but it's a race with a lot of
people, right? And where it's
interesting is what's happening during
the race, you know, not just who's in
first, but, you know, fifth, sixth,
seventh, eighth, ninth, 10th. They're
jockeying for position because that's
what's taking place in the market all
day long. When you're looking at a price
chart, you're just looking at, you know,
where the leader is, so to speak. You
know, where's price going? But, you're
not looking at how did it, you know, the
way it
the route it took to get there, you
know, over other traders or, you know,
over other competitors.
And that's why I say, you know, it's not
necessarily just about following the
leader, it's about understanding what's
taking place
everywhere else in the race. You know,
the the race for third, the race for
sixth, the race for eighth. You know,
there's always people jockeying for
position. And there's a lot of internal
movement taking place by the
institutional traders in the market,
right? The big traders, the traders that
are going to move the market.
So, one of the things that we developed
last year, or I think over a year ago
that we put in the software, but it's
still very important and
because it's it's telling you, you know,
hey,
this is where the institutional traders
are active inside of the bar.
And you're going to look for this
activity in the market and, you know,
apply it with order flow.
So, what we do, we have these things
called order flow sequencing.
Okay? And
really what it is, there's bullish
sequencing, there's bearish sequencing.
It's when the market
when a trader comes in and takes out
subsequent higher bids
in the, you know, or selling it
down like through bids. So, markets are,
you know, bid offer, okay? So, say
it's
I don't know, 21 bid
for 50,
20 bid for
60, 19 bid for 100, um 18 bid for 200,
right? That's subsequent higher bids and
a seller comes in and just wipes it all
out.
Okay? That That's what we call
sequencing. Just as the offers,
if there's more and more offers on the
way up at each price level,
higher, there's more offer, next level,
more offer than the previous level, so
on, and a trader comes and takes it out,
is,
you know,
what that's telling you, what the market
is projecting to you, is that you have a
big buyer, he doesn't care what's there
in the market, he's clearing it all out.
And you'll often see that happen in
strong moves. It's a sign of strength in
the market. So,
what we do is we color that section
of the bar magenta, so it's it's very
easy to see, right? I mean, we try to
make it as visual as possible, so it's
easier for traders to see. And, you
know, you can see here,
takes out 28, takes out 115, 119, 121,
139. You know, more and more volume on
the way down. It's just clearing it out
with impunity.
Right? And you see that often as the
market's moving down. So, it's giving
you a sign of strength in the market.
Okay? Here's another example. Right?
This is a 5-minute chart. Right? Market
looks like it's going sideways, but
right? You had this drop here down to 21
and 1/2 from 40s. But, if you're
watching what's happening up in here
while it's going sideways, you see
there's heavy selling taking place.
There's traders coming in and just
clearing out the order book. That's got
strong liquidity resting in the market.
And if you know this,
right? Then, you can take advantage of
this move.
Right? You don't want to be
having seen the market drop from 3844
down to, you know, 3834 and think, oh,
you know, I now it's time for me to get
short. No, you want to be getting short
up here at 3844
when it looks like the market is just
going sideways. But, by watching the
order flow, you know
that you have strong
institutional selling taking place in
the market.
And then the market drops. Right? That
That's the edge order flow is going to
give you. And again, similar thing here,
right? It looked like the market, you
know, it hit that low, starting to go
sideways. Some institutional selling
taking place here, even here. And the
market dropped a little bit. We didn't
take off this low, but again, you know,
the market dropped again from, you know,
the 32 area down into the mid-20s.
Gold, right? Same thing you're looking
at in
E-minis, bonds, 10s, 5s, corn, wheat.
You look at in other markets. Gold,
right? Market's going up. I I see strong
institutional buying, right? That's
these cyan zones. Obviously, I see the
deltas as well.
Then, I hit the high of the day.
But, the bar right off the high, cuz
again, you're at the high of the day.
So, what's in your mind? What should you
to thinking? What should you be focusing
on?
Is this going to be the high of the day?
Or is the market going to react and sell
off?
Well,
what happens? You hit the high of the
day. Next bar,
as it opens, the strong aggressive
selling comes in right up in here. You
got bearish sequencing.
That's why this is colored out. And the
market drops.
Okay? Well, if you're trading this,
where you place your stop is just on the
other side of that sequencing. Right? As
if you're getting long on this bullish
sequencing
down here, right? You just place your
stop below
the sequencing.
It It's, you know, it's just trade what
the market is is telling you.
Crude oil, same thing. All right? Market
had this little move up, starting to go
sideways. Now you're seeing the
institutional trading coming in here,
here.
And then the market drops. Then it met
institutional buying. Market rallies, go
sideways. Institutional selling coming
in here. Market drops again.
I mean,
don't make trading more complicated than
it needs to be.
All right? Just trade what the market is
telling you, basically.
Now, another thing that I want to talk
about is market weakness.
Okay?
You know, everyone always said, you
know, buy the dip, buy the dip, but
you try to buy this dip, and the market
keeps dipping.
All right? That That's the problem with
buying the dip is often times there's
still more
dipping to take place.
But, what if there was a way that you
can look at this sell-off and think, you
know, hey, it's going sideways, rather
than get long,
you get short.
Well, there is, all right? It's by
looking at the delta. Now, I know what
some people are going to say. They're
going to say, "Mike, you just explained,
you know, the cyan colors here, okay?
32, 33 delta volume.
Strong
delta cyan color cyan. Yeah, right.
Up until this bar here, it's looking
kind of bullish, right? I I would be
interested in buying that as well.
Off of, you know, we sort of come down
in here, we hit a swing low, we're
starting to go sideways, I'm seeing some
signs of buying.
But what I see here all of a sudden
taking place is weakness. Because
remember, for a market to move
up
in this case, you need strong aggressive
buying to take place. Market's not going
to go up on
I mean, it can go up I I in one bar, it
can have negative delta, but it's not
going to rally on bars of consecutive
negative delta. So, you'll be looking at
the delta to be stronger
each bar.
Or at least positive and sort of, you
know, somewhere around it. But what
you're seeing here,
you came down, and then you see some
signs of positive delta, 123, 109, 119.
All of a sudden it's starting to
decrease, it's getting weaker, 57, 10,
five.
Negative two, negative 179, minus 200.
That's what caused the market to sell
off, didn't it?
Sell off for any other reason that there
was no more aggressive buying. So, if
you don't have the aggressive buying in
the market,
who's going to take the market higher?
It's not going to just magically go up.
You need that buying. So, while these
two bars in here looked bullish,
you're not getting any more aggressive
buying coming in. Yeah, you had that
burst of aggressive buying, and
sometimes that's enough to kick-start it
to get it to go up. But now we're seeing
it just sort of weaken in here. That
aggressive buying has been removed from
the market, it's done. That aggressive
buying is done.
And now you're seeing weakness take
place in the market and the market sell
off. So, if you're trying to buy this
dip, initially I thought it was
potentially a nice dip to buy, but by
paying attention to how the delta was
shaping up, the lack of aggressive
buying
I'll say lack of aggressive buying
taking place but rather the the lack of
aggressive growth buying taking place
getting weaker instead of getting
stronger that's a negative sign.
And the market you know immediately
dropped 10 points.
But having software that could highlight
that to you removes that
form of analysis off your plate and just
will highlight it to you that hey you
know what there's weakness here in the
market.
Then so that you can if you were long
you could recognize that and get out and
get short basically as soon as you can.
Rather than take a full stop out because
the order flow is telling you hey you
know what the conditions for this trade
have changed.
So like I said trading is less stressful
when you know which dips to buy.
All right market went up pulls back
strong selling right you see in
strong negative delta readings
but then even though you got the strong
negative deltas it's getting weaker and
weaker.
Right it went from you know minus
you know at this high where it turned
minus 55588
delta to minus just one
58 to minus 171 to minus 159 to minus
just 85 then the aggressive buying pops
in here and the market starts to this is
just this morning
you know at 7:50 this morning to catch a
nice you know five six point move here
over
10 15 minutes.
Bonds this morning
right came down in here sort of you know
almost a double bottom.
But as this market is selling off into
this double bottom here what's happened
is the delta is weakening that
aggressive selling is getting weaker and
weaker as the market is selling off and
so imagine all right market is selling
off but
buyers are just dropping off at the
wayside.
So instead of selling off and having
more buy sorry more sellers coming in as
the market is going down which is what
you want to see for a market to go down
as the market is going down the sellers
are are falling off is getting less
sellers each bar less sellers less
sellers
and that's a sign of you know even
though we call it market strength it's
really a sign of
lack of aggressive selling which in turn
you know once that aggressive selling is
gone
the market is going to
sort of revert back to where it should
be and we actually rallied up from this
level to new highs of the day that was
this morning in the bonds.
Now I had to scrunch this chart this was
crude oil this morning just a few hours
ago well more than a few hours ago about
4:00 in the morning
until about 5:30 okay but
here you got the weakness sells off
again from you know we're talking 79
this is 7960 in here
all the way down to 7880 here where you
get
the bullish signal right that the
selling was finally tapering off right
selling was was over and then the market
rallied again from you know the 79 bucks
area up back up to 7950 so you could
have caught that move down and that move
back up but let's dig a little bit
deeper right this market this is that
same chart this was the the first
this is this area here
okay market was sort of balancing in
here
and as you're coming out of balance
the selling is just I sorry that the
aggressive buying is just not present
anymore.
And then the aggressive selling takes
over and we immediately you know drop
over a buck.
Then after that big move down, right?
This is
here,
this bar, right? Is this chart here.
After the big move down, market's
shouting out at you. I mean, look at
that big, you know, almost capitulation
bar, minus 544 delta.
Then the next bar, it drops down to just
minus 43 delta.
And then minus 21 as the market starts
reversing, we're getting a bunch of
buying imbalances taking place.
But
once you know that, hey, you know what?
This selling is over because you know, a
lot of times people see a big negative
delta
and they get more bearish. Well, okay.
You can get bearish off of the negative
delta, but you really got to watch
what's happening after that. Is it still
a strong negative delta taking place or
is it
gone? Is that selling been removed from
the market? And it has been.
Right? There's nobody else's is
interested in selling down here.
And then eventually the delta, it turns
positive and the market starts to rally.
So, the last thing I'll talk about is
leveraging the order flow to maximize
trade results. I mean, because yeah,
it's one thing to know order flow, but
then you got to start putting the pieces
together, right? I've showed you several
ways to use the order flow.
And at the end of the day, you know, you
sort of got to put the pieces of the
puzzle together and and that's what
separates good traders from
um break even traders or even losing
traders.
Is being able to put the pieces together
and understand, you know, what you're
looking at and and take good trades. So,
knowing how to leverage order flow
might just be the edge that propels you
from that average trader to a
consistently successful one. So, by
understanding relationship of order flow
such as delta, point of control, and
imbalances,
traders gain insight into the market.
So, you to start putting everything
together. Okay? This was this morning
where you had this quick pop up. I mean,
obviously now we sold off
um after this, but you know, there was a
good
4 or 5 points to be had in this quick
move here, right? This is These are
those moves that you like to see as a
trader, right? As soon as you get in,
boom, straight to your take profit in a
minute or two. But what were the signs?
Okay? Well, this market was just sort of
going sideways always going nowhere sort
of drifting down.
Then you get that green bar here. You
get that nice
delta number 209. Okay, people say,
"What about this bar here?" Well, if
it's a red candle with positive delta,
then that means something else.
But now
we're just sort of going sideways and I
see a nice positive delta. I see 209
delta. Max delta was 210, so it's
closing almost right on its max delta. I
see the min delta was just minus three,
so I see
no basically no aggressive selling. I
mean, there was minus three contracts in
there.
And more importantly, I got 1 2 3 4 5
buying imbalances in here, right? For
me, that's an easy trade to take. And,
you know, you're getting long somewhere
around 80 and it just moves up quickly
to 85.
Okay, this was a little bit earlier in
the morning, right? Market looks like
it's just sort of going sideways in here
and it was, right? From 5:30 to almost
5:40, it's just hanging around 92 to 94.
And then it drops, right? Drops from,
you know, the 92 area down all the way
into the 72, a 20-point drop in Again,
this is a 1-minute chart, so it's taking
place in 1 2 3 4 minutes, 20 points.
It's insane in the way this market is.
But what were the signs?
Okay? You got that big bar here, right?
You got
1 2 3 4 5 6 selling imbalances. Okay,
now I haven't spent much time on talking
about imbalances. That's one of the the
basics of order flow. Most traders
already know, but if you're not really
familiar with the buying or selling
imbalances, you know, watch some of my
videos on my YouTube channel. I I spent
a lot of time um talking about that.
The delta volume minus 25. So, the final
delta is minus 244,
which is off of minus 259. So, it's not
within 95%, but I know the delta, the
total delta volume
going into the volume itself is over 25%
just barely, which is a strong negative
reading.
I know that I have no aggressive buying
in this bar cuz I have a zero here.
That's what the white highlights to me
that, hey, you know what? It was zero.
There was no aggressive buying. So, what
I got? I got a market going sideways. I
start seeing some aggressive selling
taking place. Maybe I'm not convinced
yet. Maybe I see some selling. Maybe
it's going to revert back up to this 94.
Then obviously the next bar, big stack
selling imbalance. You got like 10
imbalances in this bar. This big stack
selling imbalance. Now the delta
is
magenta color. It's minus
683 versus 700 on the min delta. So, I
know that this bar is
got strong selling in it.
And it's got three positive delta. It's
white color. So, it's telling you it's
just highlighting to me that it's got a
very small small max delta. So, it's
telling me aggressive buyers never
really had control of this bar. It's
been dominated by aggressive selling.
So, even if you're getting short here at
84, a quick 10 points down to 74 in the
next 2 minutes.
Okay? That's how you know, you once you
start putting it together, you can start
to see, you know, how how
what the market is telling you
basically, right? That's all you got to
do is just trade what the market is is
telling you.
So, here, right? Market sold off, starts
going sideways, starts catching a bid,
right? Starts trading up. And what do
you see on this move up? Three nice
three green candles, nice positive
deltas closing right near our max
deltas. Even this last one, I've got
bullish sequencing. So, I know more and
more volumes are being taken out at the
upside. Again, this is 5:00 just before
6:00 in the morning this morning.
The delta volume 30 into 82, it's over
it's over 25%. It's actually 36%. So, I
got a lot of bullish activity taking
place at the swing low.
You're getting long somewhere in here,
you know, 7920. This is 20 here.
And it moves already up to 50.
Again, within about 15 minutes.
Again, you know, trade what you see,
right? These are those These are those
bars that you love as a trader, okay?
Where it moves from, you know, 80, 90
all the way up to, you know, 8140. A
50-cent move in crude oil in one bar on
a 1-minute chart.
What are the signs? Well, you could see
it in here, right? This is market just
sort of going sideways. I got bullish
sequencing here. I've got
bullish delta, right? The cyan color
7988.
It's closing near our max deltas. I see
very small min deltas. I see a zero
here. I see a minus one. I see
the delta volumes. 33% of the volume is
the positive delta. 35 is positive
delta. 40 is positive delta. Right?
Obviously, I see more s-
imbalances taking place in that bar, but
I've got a lot of bullish activity
taking place just in this little spurt
here. That yeah, okay, you get long and
then boom, it immediately just jumps up
in the next bar, goes parabolic.
And then
you're you're
These are those moves that it hits your
take profit before you can even adjust
it to a a wider take profit based off of
what you're seeing on the order flow.
And then you get some stopping volume
here. This is a very bearish bar. You
got heavy liquidity up here 241. Um and
then the market reacts to that. All
right, again, this is a very bearish
signal right here at 8150.
It's telling me there's stopping volume
in the market, that point of control up
there and the volume. And the market
sells off from there. So, you could have
caught this move up. And you know, some
of this move back down.
Now,
you know, people traders get bored in
sideways markets. They're like, "Ah, the
market's boring." But, you know, when
you read the order flow,
that's where moves you understand that
that's where moves happen from is is
when you see sideways activity in the
market.
And you know, you're starting off as
it's sort of going sideways. You get
some nice bearish sequencing taking
place here, a nice bearish delta.
And then market just continues to go
sideways. Now, it's starting to reverse.
So, even if you're short off of this
bar,
you can recognize obviously it's gotten
sideways over the next three bars. But,
now you're recognizing that the bullish
order flow is coming in. All right, you
can see the bullish deltas. See the
bullish delta into volume over this bar,
this bar. Obviously, you got a lot of
buying imbalances. This is bonds this
morning. You got 1 2 3 here. You got 1 2
3 here. This bar's got 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
buying imbalances in it.
And again, the delta volume 54%. That's
quite high.
And what happens? So, even if you're
short here, you could recognize that the
order flow is changing in here. Cut your
loss. That's That's how you cut your
loss early. I don't want to say, you
know, every single trade I'm showing you
is is going to be a winner. There's
times where it looks like, "Yeah, you
know what? This this is bearish." You
know, you get short. But, it's all about
controlling your losses. You got to cut
it.
Right? Then you got to recognize that
the order flow's turned bullish and
you're getting long 134,
you know, 25 or 20 down in here,
anywhere in here. Actually, you could
get long before this bar even starts.
But, you know, we'll just call it here
at 25 and it's a move all the way up to
50. So, even though, you know, you get
short here at 10, maybe you covered
around 15, 16, 17,
it's 25 point move right after that.
And a lot of those moves happen as the
market is coming out of sideways
activity.
Now,
this is something that gets lost on a
lot of traders, especially when
they use
order flow,
especially software that's that hasn't
been developed by me because they're
not, you know, I I don't like to say
that I sell a software package cuz I I
provide a lot of education and a lot of
live training, you know, weekly for
users and
when they you see people say, "Well,
okay, you got bullish delta here, right?
Two." Right? It's got a bullish delta
volume, 50%. Oh, that's quite big. Well,
you also got to take it in context. It's
traded four contracts, right? This is at
2:00 in the morning. This is bonds. So,
there's four contracts traded.
And, you know, it's got a delta of two.
That doesn't mean it's bullish. It's
just
you can't make a a good decision based
off of that. You know, you want to see
some decent volumes. Now, the next bar,
yeah, 170 is decent. But, when you get
over here, you're starting to see some
more
I'll say decent volumes, but good ones,
you know, 35, 61, 133 that you could
base your decision off of. Just as here.
Again, maybe you got short off of these
three bars here with the the negative
delta volume. I definitely wouldn't get
long off of a bar that's got four
contracts traded.
He's got some more volume traded. Okay,
maybe you get short here, Then you
recognize it's going sideways.
Okay, then you start to see some bullish
thing. You cover it, right? You even got
a stacked imbalance here
at 2:48 in the in the morning.
You cover your trade, right? You get
out. You don't wait for it to come back.
Right? That's trading is
being successful is about
being able to manage your your risk, you
know? And it's funny because you know,
if you I like to read trading
biographies, you know? Oh, I like to
read biographies of just people. And you
know, I spend a lot of time reading
biographies of success successful
traders. Now,
there are you know, you read Market
Wizards, okay? That's a simple book to
read in terms of biographies cuz there's
a lot there. And you know, while for
many other traders, there's there's
usually like one big singular win that
sort of propelled them from
average trader to
becoming a a professional trader, being
alive in the market for a long time. But
after that one big win,
then they start talking about managing
risk, right? Once they got to that
level. So, it's not like big win after
big win after big win after big win. A
lot of it is the grind, right? The daily
trading back and forth of cutting your
losses short
so that when the opportunity for that
big win comes in, you're positioned,
right? To take advantage of it. So, say
you get short in here and it's going
sideways. Okay, you cut your loss. When
the bullish order flow comes in, so that
when the bullish order flow comes in,
you're able to recognize it
and capitalize it as opposed to still
being married
to that
that lousy trade.
Okay, now context, okay? Put it all the
trades in context. So,
this is minis this morning, micros
rather, MES.
Market rallied up and you came up to a
swing high.
Now I got bearish sequencing coming in.
I've got bearish deltas coming in,
right? To me, that's a sign I want to
get short, right? I mean, even though
here you got some bullish signs, you
know, bullish delta, bullish delta.
Okay.
Market is kind of in a range. Maybe you
could take it. You know, if you take it,
it's got a little bit of a move. But
once you recognize that we sort of break
out to this new high and we start
turning, recognizing the turn is taking
place, uh then you start seeing the
negative deltas coming in. That's your
sign to get short,
right? It's not your sign that, oh, you
know, maybe this is just a little
pullback and I should get long. No,
that's your sign to pile in and
ride it out, right? And it drops again
another quick 10 points this morning in
the E-minis. There's a lot of 10-20
point moves this morning in the E-minis.
And this is the chart I showed you
earlier,
right? The market weakness in the sense
of
the aggressive selling, I'm sorry, the
aggressive buying getting weak before
the aggressive selling takes place. So,
imagine, right? Market is sort of
drifting down. It's got some aggressive
selling. The aggressive selling lightens
up. Some aggressive buying does come in,
but that aggressive buying has come in
and it's just sort of dropping by the
wayside. The aggressive buyers are are
dropping off one by one,
and then eventually there's no more
aggressive buying and the market starts
drifting down. But as it starts drifting
down,
aggressive sellers are piling in here.
You can see the delta volumes
What is that? 41, 56, 56. The deltas are
closing on our knee right near our max
or sorry, our min delta numbers, which
is bearish. And
the
max deltas are basically zero. You know,
these three bars, no aggressive buyers.
One This one had a one.
Zero max delta, zero max delta.
But again, the the signs were in here
that
there was
drying up aggressive buying.
This is a dip you can buy, right? Market
rallies, it starts to dipping, okay?
The aggressive selling that you're
seeing
coming in here is drying up.
Now, you got some strength appearing.
That's what this line is telling you
that, hey, you know what, that
aggressive selling that was there on
this market dipping is gone, right? This
is a dip you want to buy.
Now, I put this one in there because,
again, you know,
sometimes it's confusing, you know,
people
like to throw different things on order
flow up on the chart without really
understanding, you know, should I have
it on my chart or not? And where it gets
confusing for some people is when they
see a lot of buying and selling
imbalances in every single bar, like
this bar has got two selling imbalances.
This bar has got three buying
imbalances. This one has got two selling
imbalances. This one has got
six buying imbalances and it's followed
by a bar with four selling imbalances
followed by a bar with two three buying
imbalances. And it's just confusing,
right? Cuz if you're trying to just
trade imbalances, you're like, "Oh, I
got long. I got short. Oh, you know."
Then you want to throw your computer out
the window.
But, by watching what's happening as
well
in the deltas, okay? So, yeah, you got a
lot of back and forth actually. You'll
be buying, oh, buy, sell, no, buy, sell.
But, once you start seeing that
directional trade wind down,
right? In terms of the
aggressive selling, there's still
aggressive selling taking place here,
but it's getting weaker and weaker,
right? That's what this purple line is
telling me.
Now, that's the time I could be taking
the trade, right? Off of the aggressive
buying and the aggressive selling
getting weakened.
And it starts working its way
up nicely.
And
again, when you're looking at market
strength or market weakness, this is one
of my favorite trades. That's why I put
the star here is
when you put things in context, right?
Where should you be looking ideally for
market strength or market weakness?
Well, you want to be looking for when
strength is appearing at or near a low,
swing low, or low of the day,
or for weakness when the market makes a
swing high
or the high of the day, right? Cuz what
I want to know is
if this move going up,
even though it's going up, right? Which
is, you know, what a lot of traders like
to see a market going up, but if you're
just looking at price, you just see
price making a new high, making a new
high, making a new high. But if by
looking at things like the delta, I
could see that, yeah, it's going up,
but the aggressive buying is falling
off. It's getting a little bit weaker as
the market keeps going up. So, that
tells me that, you know, it's probably a
good short opportunity. We're at a swing
high, and as we're coming up into that
high, that aggressive buying that was
there to move it to a a swing high
is getting weaker.
Cuz once that aggressive buying dries
up, the market is probably just going to
fall over, and it drops again, really
quick from 7960
down to 7910.
It's a quick 50-cent move. Right? That's
this morning, just at 7:45 this morning
in crude.
So, trading can be a daunting experience
for many, but with the right set of
knowledge and strategies, you can learn
how to trade with order flow. And when
you join orderflows.com, I'll show you
some of my most valuable trading
experiences to guide you and make sure
that your efforts are optimally
rewarded. So, you know, we've covered a
lot of ground in the last 45, actually
almost an hour today. minutes, um
and you should know some of the ins and
outs of order flow as to how to make
smarter trading decisions. So, if you're
already using order flow and have some
software, you know, you can take away
what you learn today, but there's a way
to make it a lot easier.
And unfortunately, I can't cover
everything in a quick training session
like this and cuz there's just so much
more to learn about order flow trading.
But I hope that now you can have a good
understanding of the order flow basics,
right? Things you should be looking for,
you know, in the coming year when you're
trading with order flow.
So, I've got something special for you
guys, right? If
you know, you really want to take your
2023 to the next level in terms of
trading and especially in terms of order
flow analysis, then it's the Order Flows
Trader 6.
So, if you ever felt like you're
struggling to understand something only
to have it click into place and suddenly
become easy, all right? That's the power
of understanding how something works.
Once you understand the underlying
principles, life becomes much easier.
Not only life, but trading.
So, take trading for example. If you
don't understand how the market works
and what makes the markets move, it's
going to be very frustrating and
confusing.
So, have you ever wished you could get
inside the mind of professional traders
and see what they're thinking? And with
the Order Flows Trader, you can do just
that. You know, it's groundbreaking
software that takes the knowledge of
order flow, my knowledge, right? The
knowledge that I've gained over, you
know, 20 almost knowledge actually going
on 30 years of
market activity um and put it into a
software
that is going to highlight it to you
what you're going to see in the markets.
Now, the big mistake many traders make
is thinking that having the right
software is all they need to be
successful in trading.
And
this could not be further from the truth
cuz if you don't know how to use the
software, it's not going to do you any
good. And like I said, you know, while I
do have a software, the Order Flows
Trader 6,
I I really don't like saying I sell
software. It's really about the
education that comes with it, you know,
because you can buy order flow software
out there for Actually, there's free
versions of software out there,
footprints that you can use, but also if
you don't know what you're looking at,
it's pointless, right? That's why I
focus more on providing education on how
to trade with the order flow. I want my
students to be successful, and I know
that starts with giving them the tools
they need to understand the market. So,
once you have a solid foundation, then
you can begin to place trades with
confidence, and that's when the real
success starts to happen.
Now, this deal that I have is is the
OrderFlows Trader software 6, but also I
include the education part, the
OrderFlow Trading Course, which I
normally sell for $297. This is the
original course on trading or order
flow. Before I created this course,
there was no courses on trading order
flow.
Uh
as far as using the footprint, you're
going to get it for free with my
software. But not only that, you're
going to get access to my OrderFlow
Inner Circle video series. It's a series
of 56 videos that I made on advanced
order flow tricks, tips, and analysis.
And you you can't buy this separately.
You can only get it when you buy my
software.
So,
what you're going to get is the
OrderFlows Trader 6 software, which
normally sells for $899,
the
OrderFlow Trading Course, which normally
sells for $297, the
uh
video series, which 56 videos is
normally sells for $497 when I did sell
it. That's over $1,600, almost $1,700.
But I realize, you know what? Trading
and learning how to trade from books and
videos is one thing. It takes discipline
and commitment. What I found very
helpful to traders is live training,
where you can ask your own questions,
you know, Mike, what does this mean?
What do you think of this? What should I
be looking here? And for the last 3
years, actually this is going on 4 years
now, 2023, I've been hosting live
user training sessions each week, where
it's open for all users of the
OrderFlows Trader 6 to join, where I
drive home what I see in the order flow
for the past week.
So, you can ask your questions about
areas you may be struggling with in your
analysis or markets. And right now that
in the archives there's over 100 there's
193 episodes and it's free for all users
to attend or if you can't attend you can
watch the replay in the archives. This
is the archives and you know some gurus
out there want to charge you extra just
to teach you how to use their software.
I mean that's ridiculous. You buy
software
you should get some
training on it, all right? And I I I I I
don't like that.
And you know they I've seen them charge
up to $200 a month. Well, you got you
know once you buy our software then you
got to join our trading room for an
extra $200 a month just so you know you
can learn how to use it. Well, what's
the point of that?
So, what I discussed today is just a
sort of a small sample of the kinds of
analysis that I talk about on a weekly
basis. Now, this week because of the
holiday
um there won't be a session tonight, but
you know it'll pick up again next week.
And
you're going to go I'll go into much
more detail about you know all aspects
of trading not just order flow but
technical analysis, the fundamental
analysis. I talk about you know the
different strategies that I use.
How to adapt them to changing market
conditions, you know because most
importantly you want to be
you want to make sure you're looking at
what is current in the market in the
sense of you know what's working now.
And
much more. So, if you're serious about
trading then I highly recommend you get
started now. All right? Because you know
it's 2023, it's a new year.
So, you'll learn more about order flow
in the weekly sessions than you than you
thought possible. And as a special bonus
for Investors Expos I'll give you access
also to my order flow playbook where I
have 10 additional order flow trade
setups so you know what to look for in
the order flow. Normally I sell this
course for $297 but you're going to get
access to it for free.
So, what you're going to get is the
Order Flows Trader 6 software,
which is valued at $899, the trading
course, which is valued at $297, the
Inner Circle video series, which is
valued at $497,
the access to join in the Order Flows
live weekly group trainings, which is
valued at $200 a month.
You get access to the Order Flows
Playbook, which is valued at $297.
That's over 21 That's close to $2,200.
The value is $2,190.
But,
just for a one-time payment of $749,
again, you know, it sounds a bit, uh,
you know, and you get a free knife set.
No, you know, I I try to keep it
affordable. You know, my programmer
wants me to raise the price. I've been
trying to say, you know, it's it's I'd
rather just get the information out
there to people,
um, and and keep it at $749, but, you
know, I've I'm getting a lot of pushback
from others to raise the price. So, you
know, get it while it's still $749. Just
go to orderflows.com/oft6.html.
I'll put the link there in the chat.
And what Again, there's no recurring
monthly payments. You know, I've seen
these softwares. I've I've bought
software where it's like, oh, it's, you
know, we're just going to charge you $99
a month, and then it's like, forever.
You even cancel your card or your card
expires, somehow they still charge you
for that like months afterwards. I I
hate that, and, you know, I I don't It's
just a one-time payment. Now, you will
have to pay data fees, obviously, and
any NinjaTrader fees, cuz the Order
Flows Trader 6 runs on NinjaTrader.
And all you do is just go to
orderflows.com/6.html, scroll down this
page.
It's going to take you to this thing
here where you can see what you're going
to get. All right? Again,
normal My guys, they
my
programmer wants me to raise the price
to $999, but I'm still holding it at
$749. You're going to get the software,
the Order Flows Trader software, the
trading course, the Inner Circle video
series,
access to the weekly live group
trainings,
access to the order flow playbook. Just
click that button, it takes you to
PayPal. PayPal processes your payment.
I don't get your credit card. I don't
want that information. PayPal handles it
all. I do get notified. Now, do bear in
mind after you
click
um
through PayPal, it does take it can take
a few hours to get everything all set up
because, you know, to get access to you
know, the trading courses and
everything, you have to manually go in
and set that up as well as create your
license manually because this is not
it's not automatic, right? You're
getting a lot of extra bonuses in here.
So, um we're usually pretty quick on it,
you know, usually within 30 minutes to
an hour, but, you know, depending on,
you know, we just had a holiday, so
everyone was busy um during the holiday,
but again, you know, just give it some
time. Don't email me 1 minute afterwards
saying that you haven't gotten it
because it it takes time to manually go
in and give you access to all these
special bonuses.
So, just get started now, right? Go to
orderflows.com/6.
html. Make sure you put the .html.
And it's just $7.49 to get started. Now,
if you want my book, I wrote a book on
trading order flow. It's 150 pages.
You're not going to get an actual hard
cover copy. You're going to get a
digital download. Just go to
orderflows.com/book.html.
It'll take you to this page. Enter your
name and email, hit submit.
And it'll take you directly to the
download page. So,
again, you know, get started with the
order flows trader 6. You get a great
deal. Just go to orderflows.com
/oft6.html.
And I'll see you guys on the inside. So,
again, you know, thanks for taking the
time out to get this. January 3rd, it's
just the third day, really the first
business day of the new year.
And I hope to see you guys, you know, on
our weekly sessions and also you guys
can become better traders and improve
your trading um
knowledge. So, thanks everyone for
taking the time out and I'll see you
guys on the inside. Bye-bye.